well matt hancock was telling us earlier
about the pressure on the nhs and of
course it's something that's been felt
by those working on the front line
including paramedics and those people
driving ambulances well tracy nichols is
the chief executive of the college of
paramedics and she joins us now
how much pressure is the ambulance
service under
uh it's under unprecedented pressure um
sophie we're very used to seeing
ambulance services
um take some strain over the winter
months due to
the normal pressures that you'd see any
particular year
but but this year particularly has seen
incredible pressure
because of uh the clinical presentation
of the patients that
the our members are seeing um they are
sicker
and and we are seeing this incredible
bottleneck
despite the herculean efforts of both
our paramedics and ambulance staff and
the
emergency department teams we're seeing
the ambulance handover delays
at a scale we haven't seen before we've
all seen of course
those images of ambulances backed up
outside hospitals waiting
to get the patients inside how long are
ambulances having to wait outside
hospitals and is that putting patient
safety at risk
so i think it's different across the
country
and we've seen certainly in london and
the southeast an increased level of
pressure
recently our members have reported to us
that they can wait as little as half an
hour
uh we've had some members who've waited
five six seven eight and even nine hours
nine hours nine hours and that's with a
patient for their experience we know
that patient experience
if that's poor that can affect clinical
outcomes
but i would say sophie the hidden risk
is that you can your your
your viewers can see the ambulances at
the hospitals that doesn't take into
account the huge number of patients that
are waiting for an ambulance
that can't get to them so the control
room staff who are also doing a
fantastic job are holding those calls
until they can get a response it's very
true the sort of hidden
delays how long are people having to
wait for ambulances
so for the immediate category one calls
the life-threatening calls there doesn't
appear to be
too many delays for category two calls
we have seen in those high pressure
areas around
london in the south east slight delays
of maybe an additional 10 minutes
is really those category three and four
calls those category three calls would
be things like abdominal pains or falls
and some of those patients in those high
pressure areas have waited up to 10
hours
up to 10 hours for an ambulance and i
guess as you say you know these are
category 3 and 4
it's not deemed to be life-threatening
but at the same time people need
ambulances for these things
that's the reason that they're calling
them right absolutely and and you know
we we are
cognizant of the fact that our members
are working in an environment
particularly in this weather where
if someone falls outside for example the
people in the call center will try their
absolute utmost to try and get a
response to somebody
um but it's it's really frightening when
you're waiting for an ambulance even if
it arrives in in minutes
it's a scary thing for a patient to wait
for an ambulance
it's worth talking as well isn't it that
you know covert is having an impact on
people who don't
have covert as well who have other
health problems
who need ambulances i'm thinking of
anyone from you know someone having a
stroke to someone having a fall to
someone
even having a home birth for example and
then needing potentially to go to
hospital
is there a risk that if the nhs
continues to face the kind of pressure
it's under now cases are still rising
that you might not be able to get an
ambulance that you need
because of the pressure i think it is a
potential risk
and you know we are open for business as
is all the nhs the
the ambulance services are doing an
amazing job under difficult
circumstances
and we really want people who who have
those conditions to call the stroke
networks are still open
the heart attack centers are still open
the trauma networks are still open
um we really do need people to
understand that
um kobe doesn't preclude them from
getting help and can
but but i'm sure it's frightening for
people to to think that
um because of the pressures from kobe
that they may
somehow not be able to get an ambulance
in the same way
when i was researching this interview
read some reports um
mainly from kind of local newspapers
around london saying that you know some
people are having to be transported
in police cars or even fire engines and
because they can't
get the ambulance as they need is that
happening um
we we know of rare occasions where that
does and
and certainly i know london ambulance
service have engaged with
london fire brigade and and the met
police to
to try and um spread the load of of
paramedics and clinicians
um across the the capital so that uh the
ambulances can get there so people
aren't conveyed in a
in a less safe environment uh such as an
ambulance but
um you know that does bring with it its
own risk so i understand from our other
emergency service colleagues that if
you're waiting on scene
with someone who you think is ill you
haven't been able to necessarily
clinically assess them in the same way
you're going to do whatever you think is
right
just finally we've known for quite a
long time that
winter peak of covert 19 was likely
to happen and bringing with it increased
pressure we know the nhs has always
under increased pressure in winter
anyway
and yet here we are you know not enough
staff not enough beds
ambulances backed up against outside
hospitals sometimes
up to nine hours what were the
contingency plans drawn up were you
involved in these contingency plans
uh the college wasn't but that's not
necessarily a surprise the
the ambulance services were there there
are you know it's part of the critical
infrastructure
of the country so uh they absolutely
were but i think
what what wasn't anticipated you know
the new variant has
has ripped through uh the population and
um you've got staff who are uh are you
know
really trying hard to come in even if
they're not feeling great themselves
not with kovid you know if they test uh
positive for covid they're doing the
right thing
um but they're frightened that they're
gonna introduce infection they work
predominantly in the communities but
certainly i think this has superseded
all the plans that we we could have had
but uh we do need to um support
the paramedic and ambulance workforce
with with good protection so they
protect the patients that's what
everybody wants to do
and we really need to work together to
try and stem this bottleneck that's
happening at the emergency departments
thank you you've spoken really
powerfully about the you know pressure
that your staff
and the ambulances are under so we
really appreciate you coming on thank
you
thank you sophie